let's say the surface of the crystal
looks like this it's slightly miscut
well the problem with that is i'm
breaking bonds here i'm breaking bonds
here and breaking bonds
391 is what we call a general institute
requirement
the learning outcomes are all the same
chemical principles
as you would get in a university
chemistry course
but the vehicle that you use to study
those chemical principles
are solids the surface tension is just
going to be the derivative there's no
textbook for the class
the online material that developed for
309.1x
is the textbook for the class because
the online content
is so well organized and it perfectly
matches my
course i don't feel so pressured in
lecture
to cover all the material
it's okay for me to stop and talk to
students
take questions or do examples it stays
relatively constant
what we did was get rid of all the
midterms and finals
and converted them all to an online
assessment
in a proctored environment if they
pass it they know instantly because the
computer grades it
if they don't pass it they can come back
and do it again the next day
it seems like the assessments almost
fulfill the purpose of the tests and the
homework simultaneously somehow
compared to my other classes where you
know we have written exams
every like few weeks or so it's
definitely been a lot less pressure and
stress than those
i'm a little more free to come in when
i'm ready to take the assessments and do
them whenever
these tools were built for the edx
platform and
it's great because it's like
automatically generating a brand new
quiz
each time the student sits down i
learned that
some of the assumptions that we make
about how to best do a student
assessment
may be flawed my
outcomes measures are not you knowing
something
but you being able to do something the
nice thing about when they go back in
they got a little practice under their
belt if they failed once before and so
they've gone to talk to a ta
so like if you get down all the way to
like see
two what would that look like and so by
the second time
the achievement rate is much much
greater
the problems that are in our database
are exactly the same problems that
appeared on 3091
exams in the past 30 years so
i don't think it's any easier i think
it's just a better way to measure
and least stressful way to measure it's
got a nitrogen plus here at the end
this is an experiment we'll study the
outcomes
i'm a scientist and so i'm doing my best
to
have the appropriate controls i'm
getting a sense that this is a
sea change in the way 309.1 is going to
be taught
the course will never be the same as it
was
going forward because of this experience
there will be it'll be better
hey thanks a lot i really appreciate
your help this semester
you